back to pack okay then let's play again
so see for ya what's what to do okay
let's let's do some e five it's probably
the best move anyway let's see i'm just
going for normal development normal
development here not not going for four
crazy stuff i got probably cancel just
I'm just trying to play the super solid
development system here and style of
carp or sometimes called the cup of
variation usually though with another
and f3 so this is a little bit different
as some as here yeah white has those
additional options to play night to d5
okay um if I take this now I don't like
to take it I have to admit that right
away yeah i can try not to d7 than 97
this kind of thing maybe start with this
covering them and be porn is often
useful
I have this idea Knight to d7 and knight
to e7 well it's very slow I wonder if I
should just take and stand take not 97
and then place is six but white looks
better than yeah but this is looking
slow it looks like a very slow plan you
might you might just play you for now
for example yeah but okay it's it's it's
actually um sometimes a bit difficult
from this position to be really really
really worse because it is such a such a
healthy set up in terms of peace play it
just it just very very classical that
same so you're often not in such such
bad shape okay um if I take on d4 he
will take with the night it's not
looking too great c6 takes takes also
slightly better for wine at least but
anyway I have to probably do that let's
not stop the end of the world this
position okay d fire fan okay of course
white is bad out but this is also giving
my bishop some more scope down so f5
know or not i think at 5i should be
happy that i get some kind of activity
here at five in the night f6 the bishop
187 is not a bad piece at all i think
critical could be some air force stuff
ma'am is going for that if i take theirs
f5 this is this is an issue so probably
will get a TMI tag the night takes the
night f4 hmm
hmm okay how would you play takes 90 x
is really kind of annoying hmm okay yeah
but probably probably not much choice
let's do it okay if it really looks very
logical he takes it 95 night fo I'm just
going to take it for and play for the
play for the pieces that are not so bad
Bishop on 87 is making a pretty good
impression I don't think you can take
just sex but i'm not positive that this
is so great night of nights to see force
also move here it's something that i
should have considered maybe a little
bit more closely okay if you take g6 i
can also probably just take with the
night you know the the porno de force is
secure okay some hmm okay I cannot do 93
here unfortunately I can go III keep the
porn like that yeah maybe it's not so
easy to get it back now unless no Bishop
c1 is not actually threatening much my
idea is also maybe to use the C 2 square
somehow
also difficult now if i am to move the
night as Bishop d3s is also an option
okay I'll just bring rook c2 into this
currently can answer this with 96 but
it's part of the part of the position
now this idea so he has to be on the
lookout yeah it's not easy not easy to
play
and maybe Bishop c2 was actually an idea
okay so i have two options taking with a
pawn it's not totally insane night on e
5 is a strong piece that really is but I
don't know Bishop deform okay I'll take
that the pond and see that i keep my
active 995 course now this roxy tip see
to business assume is gone from the
position here and grab here and see this
is looking kind of tricky for him look
here trying to win the Queen Bishop a
seven Bishop e3 out a planar g four wins
the Queen so it's a bit of a problem now
for him look after was pretty awful okay
so he decided to give her the Queen I
came so how to do that now it's not easy
it's not not a totally simple win at
least I I don't see a simple win
trying to infiltrate and maybe get get
to win some points and would help
enormously Luke you see one I think I'll
just take them take a three take before
no no that's a look white resins tough
game it didn't look so great here for
wider for me here but I don't think it
was so bad i mean whole piece design
play somehow so this this was the idea
and now deform it looks very very
logical it's an interesting question if
is why it should actually close the
center this is this kind of thing i mean
i don't think it can be bad for white
but it's not clear that it really gives
them given the best possible outcome
here I actually think what this makes
sense here I think is to try to prevent
a five I mean I think this is something
that I'm happy about to get some play
there that Bishop is is doing something
and this is ambitious but i'm not sure
how good it is okay interesting is that
the engine just wants to take and does
not really think f5 is any issue this is
the engines move okay so it probably it
probably believes that or h5 this is
interesting directly attacking and for
queen here yeah okay that makes
excellent offer a lot of sense with the
bishop being here okay i didn't see that
one man at all so f for probably is not
great because I should take your form I
stopped after seeing at five thinking
that this cannot be
great so that was a bad calculation okay
I mean this is ok but not more than that
and here taking here White's position
becomes critical he doesn't get the
puppy doesn't get the porn back simply
oh yeah I missed a very strong move oh
wow yeah that the kind of move that yeah
this is very strong and not this not my
move this move is strong very good time
that's a very good idea not easy to see
for me let's say in a blitz game yeah
the bishop didn't look so bad on g67 but
it's even better here and Bishop g5 is
this is a winning positioner computers
on minus two he cannot prevent this has
to play very awkward stuff now iconic
image oops just a second here I was
strong very strong but ok I was thinking
to use the bishop on its square so you
felt that you should take and now this
position no it's just not good in here
who cook f1 Bishop takes oh oh no I'm
not very nice I am mr. I with some nice
shots here here this is winning takes
takes and a very nice move Roxy too whoa
it's really cute huh J very cute and he
cannot prevent it too very nice there is
a flat win ok i played this which which
also wins ok but that was much more
convincing them why doesn't really have
a move here anymore it's really an issue
you cannot move the King anyway a
meaningful I mean let's say
yeah I'll take oops I'll take T and this
one this is the thing is very much got
tied up him I don't really know how he
should yeah if this is also winning
check Jenna and this was what happened
Jericho in f3 he will lose stuff but ok
he blundered the rube now but it will be
difficult as he loses a 3 and possibly
before later so it's not so easy
sometimes here to win against rock and
Bishop with the Queen but here i will i
will win a couple of pounds which is
very helpful ok well thanks for watching